What are you gonna do as a stay at home mom all day?
Those people are people that have never been around children
to understand how much work children are.
Not only that, what it takes to keep a home tidy is a lot of work.
Yeah. Now a lot of women feel shame around this,
which is just so sad. They go,
I wanna be a housewife.
You wanna even know what their own fathers will tell them?
What are you gonna do all day?
Idiots say that. People who've never actually understood
what it takes to build a household
and to have. By the way,
the next strong generation is a present mother who's in the home
building one cause. In the home is where you build a family.
There's a family, there's the individual.
And that's what can change the world.